[Music]
[Music]
control is this constellation starship
frontier
we're ready to start on your signal
[Music]
two
one
[Music]
it's hard to express how excited all of
us at bethesda are to be here with you
today we're so grateful you're spending
the time and we know you've waited a
long time to finally see
starfield it's easily our most ambitious
game ever like our previous games it's
an epic role-playing game where you get
to be who you want and go where you want
but this time you'll be exploring space
so let's jump right in this is early in
the game as you arrive on the mysterious
moon of crete
[Music]
[Music]
according to the scanners the abandoned
research facility is in this direction
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
it would appear that pirates of the
crimson fleet are using the facility
someone trying to kill my school
hey
we've got company
you're gonna pay for that
after some initial encounters you're
invited to join constellation who in the
future the game is set in are the last
group of space explorers to meet them
you'll head to the capital city of new
atlantis
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to constellation we have a lot
to talk about
we're all here because we're committed
to the biggest question of all
what's
out
there these artifacts could be
everything we've been looking for
as to what they are
what they're building
[Music]
you'll be part of solving that puzzle
now
so you found something the new guy found
it
you dug up the artifact right that means
you saw it the visions
the artifact you found appears to be one
of many scattered across the galaxy
if we can find more we can unlock their
secrets beautiful isn't it the man who
sold me this told me that it spoke to
him of course the settle systems is full
of groups with other priorities
that's the crimson fleet everybody get
ready the fleet doesn't follow the rules
agreed to work for uc system together we
take down these cutthroat pirates
we're not just here to shoot the bad
guys we're peacekeepers we protect the
people of the freestar collective
when you sign up with the crimson fleet
no one quits
the only way out
is death
the path ahead may be dangerous
but we are not stopping
most dusties don't even make it this far
because whatever lies at the end of this
road
will change humanity
forever
that gives you a look at the stories in
starfield but ultimately it's not our
story it's the story you create by who
you are and the choices you make and
that starts with character creation
[Music]
it's our most flexible yet
you can customize all the elements of
how you look
[Music]
you'll pick a background that gives you
three starting skills
[Music]
says here you spend some time as a
diplomat having a way with words might
prove useful
there are optional traits and these come
with unique advantages and disadvantages
but it's not just in how you can look
but how your character plays and
develops
the skill system combines the best from
our previous games
and you can unlock new skills as you
level up and then you rank those skills
up by using them and completing
challenges
and there's deep crafting systems from
running research projects with resources
you find
to crafting weapon mods needed to
survive
[Music]
and you can build your own outposts
these act as a home away from home for
survival and resource generation
you can choose where and how to build
each one
and you can hire characters you meet to
keep it up and running
but
that's not all
[Music]
you can even build your own spaceships
[Music]
you can choose crew members
and yes you can completely customize the
look and layout
there's loads of different modules ship
manufacturers and more
i have to say it's so cool we just
absolutely love this
[Music]
it's not just how the ship looks it's
how it performs from engines to shields
to weapon systems
because yes
you can fly it
frosters
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we can't wait for all of you to
experience the game thanks again for
being with us today and thanks for all
the support you've given us over the
decades especially on this game it's
been an incredible journey for us making
it but we know
that's really only the beginning for
it's when all of you play it that the
real journey begins
and you may be wondering just how big is
this game
so we thought we'd take one last moment
and show you
let's take a look at one of our planets
jemisin
you can land into atlantis
but you can also land and explore
anywhere on the planet
and it's not just this planet
it's all the planets in the system
from barren but resource heavy ice balls
to goldilocks planets with life
and not just this system
but over a hundred systems
over 1 000 planets all open for you to
explore
we can't wait
to see what you find
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
play it day one with game pass